covering your women that's the dumbest
ever these guys can't control their
urges so they gotta cover their women up
like they're Daft Punk
I don't want to be around the bush have
you heard of the saving Masjid project
your brothers and sisters are Islam yet
are establishing a one of his kind
Masjid dawah and Community Center in the
capital of Norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts Islam through the center every
river who learns about their Deen and
calls their family to the worship of
Allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video
foreign
so I came across this guy what's his
name Ray William Johnson Ray William
Johnson I don't know what his name is I
just came across the stick talk and I
found a bit bizarre let's watch it for
ourself and let's see what his problem
is and what he found so funny is this
funny or is it sad so in Afghanistan
under the Taliban rule they are required
to either cover the heads of their
female mannequins or take the heads
completely off sometimes they'll even
put tinfoil over the mannequin's faces
and I guess this is so men don't lust
after them what kind of Dark Ages both
what is this if you think tinfoil is
gonna stop me from lusting you haven't
seen the way I look at a baked potato
I'm sorry covering your women that's the
dumbest ever these guys can't control
their urges so they gotta cover their
women up like they're Daft Punk
so there you go a another Caucasian man
who wants to come and save and rescue
the Muslim world you know in the
meantime while he's living in a
degeneracy
um where you can we can see where the
Western world is going that people like
Andrew Tate and his likes have become so
popular because they are fed up of
seeing the direction going through now
let me educate you Mrs Ray William
Johnson whatever your name is yes the
Taliban or the people in power in
Afghanistan are not doing that because
they cannot control their self you know
Mrs Caucasian white man who can control
himself because he can go and sleep
around whoever he wants whenever he
wants and use an abuse a woman like
they're a piece of crap like a jacket
potato like he was mentioning yes he can
just access him whenever he lacks I mean
if you think about it these women are
nothing but toilets to you because
anytime you want to go we or go who you
have to use a toilet to relieve yourself
you do the same thing with these women
you just want to relieve yourself inside
of them so they're like walking toilets
to you so for you to come and question
um a group of people who you might look
and be like these barbarians you know
yeah yeah what makes you what principles
do you use to justify that your way of
life is better than their way of life
that's the question that needs to be
asked they cover the faces and get rid
of the mannequins because of the saying
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him about Image Makers so that is
actually more close to punishment
because of making drawing images the
ruling comes to that not because the men
find it enticing or whatever it may be
and to be honest actually talking about
this there was actually a study done
that showed that men actually summoned
actually some men get turned on by
mannequin so it's not a far-fetched
reality not that I'm saying they do it
because of that reason but in the
Western World there are some people in
your world view and your countries in
the western world who follow liberal
values that actually find mannequins you
know they have a fetish for mannequins
so this is a problem that is more
prevalent in this country in the Western
World in our country than it is there in
their countries so just because you
misjudged it and thought they're just
covering them just because oh it's such
a desire that they cannot control
themselves it's absolutely nonsense my
friend and funnily enough you find this
fetish of looking as mannequins and
getting turned on in the Western World
Isn't that ironic maybe next time
educate yourself and talking about
covering a woman as the dominant ever
really really so do you believe that um
we are more um we are more liberated the
more women show their skin really the
more sexualizing their self do you think
this is the way to go about yeah is this
what you think liberalism is do you
think this is liberating that woman
choose to in the winter cold minus three
degrees dress up in mini skirts and wear
this much high heels with full of Caked
Up makeup and hair that is not even real
you think that is liberating and you do
not feel that that is oppression you do
not think that these women are are not
forced or coerced in one way or another
to dress up and behave in that way
beauty industry peer pressure pleasing
men the opposite gender none of these
play a role really the Western woman
want to dress up like this and dress up
in ministers in cold weather absolute
garbage so the biggest BS I've heard is
from your mouth when a woman covers up
she is choosing to control her sexuality
that you talk to her not to talk to
somewhere else my friend yes because
maybe you're used to and desensitized to
seeing half naked girls left right
center you believe that your worldview
which is the fallacy of presentism that
you have the best world view and that is
the best for the whole world no it's not
you have no premises no points not
nothing to prove that so next time
before you open your mouth and talk
about this maybe you should buy a book
called Beauty sick and it would maybe
educate you to the pandemic of billions
of women around the world who are sick
in Beauty yes they're Beauty sick they
are too busy starving their self to have
the perfect body yes getting their nose
done their backs are done their breasts
done and in the process dying literally
dying to look a certain way because
they're not happy with their self where
Islam has come to liberate the woman so
they can be a woman who has a service to
the world rather than going to only fans
and showing their backside or whatever
it may be to make some money Islam has
come to honor woman and have told the
men that they should lower their gaze
and a woman to do their part we are both
told to dress up modestly hope this has
brought or shed some light of light to
your ignorance till next time for myself
and mannequin fetishes goodbye